la carte de crédit un mode de paiement
très populaire neuf canadiens sur dix en
possèdent au moins une et vous est ce
que vous payez chaque mois oui je la
paye chaque mois mais je fais attention
de pas là de palal hauts des bas ces
deux hommes font partie des 70 % de la
population qui paie la totalité du sol
de chaque mois
quant aux autres ils devront débourser
davantage pour le paiement mensuel
minimum le taux augmentera d'un demi
point pour atteindre 2,5 pour cent si
vous payez deux et demi pour cent du
solde à chaque mois le rythme de
remboursement diminue de moitié et les
frères crédit diminue de moitié à eux
aussi donc un petit effort
supplémentaire peut signifier beaucoup
d'argent dans nos poches par exemple
vous achetez un téléviseur à 1000 $ sur
une carte de crédit dont le taux est à
19,9 pour cent avec un taux de paiement
minimal à 2%
il vous faudra 25 ans pour tout
rembourser et la télévision vous aura
coûté quatre mille dollars mais avec un
taux de paiement minimal à 2,5 pour cent
il vous faudra dix ans de moins pour
vous libérer de cette dette et la
télévision vous aura coûté 2444 dollars
cette hausse du taux minimum a débuté
l'an dernier après que québec a adopté
un projet de loi pour prévenir le
surendettement
l'objectif est d'augmenter le taux au
rythme d'un demi point chaque année pour
atteindre 5 % en 2025
mais cette année le quart des québécois
ont eu davantage recours au crédit
selon un sondage de québec retraite
l'aco vide ne fait qu'empirer les choses
puis si ça se règle rapidement mis ce
qui quand même peu probable
à mon avis mais peut-être qu'on peut
récupérer la situation mais je crois
qu'il ya des gens qui vont être de plus
en plus endettés certaines personnes
devront retarder leur retraite de cinq à
dix ans estime la conseillère qui est
des gens qui vont évidemment non ports
non plus qu'ils ne sont plus capables
d'économiser
il ya des gens aussi qui ont dû retirer
derrière qui ont dû retirer des
placements qui était pour l'objectif de
leur retire actuellement la coved 19
n'aura pas fini de faire des vagues sur
le portefeuille des canadiens
il s'y marie josée paquet comme radio
canada montréal